all of us have moments whether we're out
surfing whether we're cooking there are
moments where all of our attention and
our awareness and we're in these flow
states are on the experience that we're
having but there's also ways to tap into
that and meditation is one way but
breath work is also another way and
breath workers have been around as long
as meditation has been around from all
the way in a judeo-christian times to
you know the yogis that taught ways to
control this thing that we all have
which is our breath to elicit a certain
feeling meditation is something that
changes your mind over a period of time
breath work is something that changes
your physiological State just like that
you know you might only have five
minutes if you're lucky a day so what
can you do for five minutes every single
day that's going to build this skill
within you and it's a bit like going to
the gym and doing squats if you do
squats once a week it might be great but
you're probably not going to see much
benefit from that over a period of time
it's better than nothing but it's also
not really going to develop any sort of
muscle there and it's like meditation as
well if you all you do is five minutes
every single day you'll begin to see a
life as opposed to maybe sitting 30
minutes once a week so these little
incremental moments where you're deeply
present deeply cultivating your mind can
really add up and it won't show in the
practice it'll show like when you're
interacting with your kids or your own
mind in all those Quiet Moments and then
you'll realize oh and I have nothing to
do and there's no one else there
actually okay like this moment is
actually kind of I'm fine with myself
[Music]
that was manage Diaz a speaker and
meditation teacher born in Sri Lanka and
later raised in Australia he's helped
thousands of people around the world in
their meditation practice to improve and
transform their life from Gaining New
Perspectives and stressful situations
increasing patience tolerance and
presence and cultivating a disciplined
life Manoj brings the cumulative power
of compassion awareness and wisdom by
combining ancient wisdom and
contemporary science to large
organizations including Netflix and
Google he's also an associate at the
Melbourne Business Schools executive
leadership program and became
Australia's first and only Lululemon
Global Ambassador in 2019. in this
episode Manoj shares his personal story
with anxiety that led to the breakdown
of his health he eventually landed in a
yoga class which brought him to a
meditation journey of mindfulness
healing and now teaching others what he
has learned he breaks down how to start
a meditation practice and the reasons
why the benefits of breath work how to
be more present and connected in your
life and why it's so hard to quiet our
mind and how only 5 minutes a day of
meditation can change your life I
definitely needed this conversation as I
tend to be someone who's always on the
go and hustling to check things off my
list so this episode really hit home for
me and combining the tools he shares in
this conversation can not only lower the
stress in our lives promoting longevity
and health but also bringing us to the
present moment in everyday tasks like
being with our children and doing daily
chores I hope you enjoy our conversation
welcome to the Ellen Fisher podcast
[Music]
okay guys I'll be the first to admit
that I love pretty things so if I find a
product that nourishes me and looks
beautiful on the kitchen counter I am
all in anima Modi herbals does just that
they carry organic wild crafted and
ethically grown Botanicals in the most
beautiful packaging from Elderberry
syrup and adaptogenic mushrooms to
spirulina chocolate protein teas and
collagen booster powders every vibrant
and medicinally potent remedy is
packaged in eco-friendly packaging a
recyclable glass or biodegradable bags
it was founded by Costa Rican herbalist
Adriana ayalas who uses over 200
different sustainably grown herbs from
around the world to create intentional
products that contain zero fillers
binders or flow agents everything is
made in the U.S with certified organic
wild crafted and sustainably harvested
plants and herbs in a vegan and
gluten-free kitchen I love their High
potency Elderberry syrup which is double
extracted it's adaptogenic anti-viral
organic and wild crafted perfect for
supporting healthy immune function so
use my code ln20 for 20 off just click
the link in my show notes to get this
deal from an amazing company that
supports Fair Trade Practices Beyond
organic farming education and small
farmers to create remedies that benefit
people from all walks of life thank you
manage for being here how are you liking
Hawaii so far oh my gosh I think I
mentioned to you and your assistant
alarm before I'm already thinking about
ways I can move out of here don't tell
the rest of the open Team I know a lot
of people say that it's so nice is this
your first time in Hawaii first time in
Hawaii yeah but what about your fiance
and congratulations by the way how long
have you guys been together we've been
together four years we took a little
break for about a year and then came
back and I popped the question recently
that's amazing congratulations so I want
to get into your story and I'm wondering
if you could just share a little bit
about how what led you to you know the
place that you are at today at teaching
people with meditation and mindfulness
how did you get to where you are right
now um
um I mean there's so many different
factors I feel that always leads you to
a particular point in your life or a
place in your life so there wasn't
necessarily one particular thing but you
know I grew up in Sri Lanka and the
first six years of my life and I had
this connection to spirituality which I
didn't really understand fully at that
point you know we lived close to a
monastery so lots of monks Buddhist
monks lots of temples we heard the
Chimes the songs the chanting and there
was some sort of connection there but I
didn't quite get what it was and it
wasn't until we migrated to Australia
and you know in my 20s was working in
banking and finance and advertising and
I had a panic attack that um I had to
really ReDiscover what those early
moments really meant for me and they
formed part of the healing that I
experienced and you know I went through
a really bad period of physical and
mental health ranging from you know
extreme insomnia anxiety panic attacks
depression to um like physical ailments
like I had disordered eating my mother
was looking after me for a period of
time and it was reconnecting to
spirituality that really began to help
me first of all understand my mind and
in the process
um understand what was going to help me
get well and get better and so then you
journeyed on to this like meditation
journey and like how did you start to
see how powerful it was in your own life
yeah I mean like I was it was like an
alpha male growing I'm not I don't know
if that term even means much these days
but like you know growing up and I was
playing all the sports I was I had a big
group of male friends we'd go drinking
we'd go partying like that was my life
for such a long period of time and I
never would have thought that you're a
good meditation any of that would offer
me any sort of value I used to look at
it I'm like what a waste of time I could
stretch at home and you know all that
sort of stuff but
um you know going through that period of
being really sick I tried lots of
different Western
um
avenues for for getting well like
psychologists psychiatrists medication I
had an addiction at a certain point to
some of the medication and it was a very
strange set of circumstances that
eventually led me to a class and
essentially my friend came over one day
he's like hey come and do a yoga class
with me and I was like no I don't own
any Lululemon I can't go and he's like
no no come it'll be great and I'm like
no I can't even touch my toes and he's
like no but there's lots of hot girls
there's a car and I'm like
I was pretty unwell you know physically
I was emaciated at that point but um he
sent me the details of the of the
teacher and I looked at him and he was
this really beautiful looking Sri Lankan
man he looked I couldn't tell if he was
male or was female because you know he
had such a beautiful like eyes and
cheeks and Chin I remember sending him
an email saying these are all my
problems
and he messaged me back you know within
an hour and he's like I've been waiting
for you come tomorrow and um that was
the first moment I was like this is
weird like did my friend say something
and um I remember going to class and you
know hot girls there by the way
um it was all like people over the age
of 60 and 70 that were there and he was
teaching like really gentle stretches
and then he was teaching essentially
Buddhist Meditation practice and
mindfulness and he was talking a lot
about understanding suffering and
understanding the mind and how the mind
causes so much of our suffering and then
also how the suffering wasn't personal
it wasn't my suffering it wasn't me that
was anxious and all that sort of stuff
and I had a moment in that class where I
really began to observe the thoughts
that were going through my mind you know
you're a failure you're never going to
be well again what are you going to do
for work all of these different things
and there was a moment of real
separation between me and what I was
observing and that was the first moment
of as I like to think of it conscious
mindfulness I was able to witness my my
mind without really attaching everything
that was happening in my mind to who I
was
and then I came back the next day and
the next day next day and actually ended
up studying with him every day for eight
years
um at a certain point I thought I was
going to be a monk I was going to go to
Sri Lanka take robes go down that path
but decided not to do that and again
fell into teaching because
um you know at one point I was dating
someone and I wanted to impress her and
she was doing a yoga teacher training
and I'm like oh okay I'll come with you
and I'll do yoga teacher training and I
did the training with no intention of
being a teacher and then the studio
asked me to teach afterwards and at that
point my meditation teacher was was
seeing all this happening and he was
seeing that I had a talent for teaching
and he asked me to come and teach at his
Studio which could only fit like 12
people and um the rest is kind of
history from there that's amazing I am
definitely gonna be honest here and
meditation is something I've never given
enough time to really develop any kind
of practice with it anytime that I've
you know taken the time okay I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do like a five minute
10 minute meditation you know click on
something and normally I'm finding just
like that it's immediate discomfort of
just sitting alone with nothing to to
even you're supposed to just observe
your thoughts right even just that it
can be uncomfortable I think that's one
reason why so many people struggle to
make it a normal practice and I also am
the type of person too where I'm like
okay what's going to give me the most
bang for my buck I have a super busy
life I don't have time for this
meditation junk you know like I'm like
when I'm working out like for my my
sister loves yoga and when she got into
yoga she found such a transformation of
her life not only physically but
emotionally spiritually
she found it super beneficial to her
life and I would tell her like I don't
have time for yoga you know I got I got
five kids four four kids at the time or
maybe three when she started I can't
remember
um and so I'm like I just want to do the
shortest workouts I can do that is going
to give me the biggest results
physically never considering like the
emotional benefits to things like
meditation and mind mindfulness breath
work any of that stuff it's so often for
me to just be like okay well I gotta get
this done this is the maximum benefits
I'm gonna see the best physical results
and the kids are all over me and
everything but then I opened your app
for the first time
and I clicked on
um it was a meditation one and and you
were speaking and you said a quote that
was something about if you don't have
time to meditate then you should sit for
an hour something like that and that
just hit me like wow yeah like I really
I really should be making that a
priority well I mean I think it's it's
worthwhile understanding why you should
be making it a priority because for so
long we've been told meditation is good
for you and even me before I went to a
class everyone's like oh you should
meditate it's like when people say to
you you know you should drink this or
you should try this diet I'm like yeah
and it conceptually it makes a lot of
sense that I should do that but I've got
a mind that I had a mind that couldn't
stay still and I was diagnosed with ADHD
some of mine was all over the place
um I was busy I was you know very high
powered job I was very young I was very
stressed out very burnt out drinking too
much caffeine all of those things
um so first of all it's understanding
why why should we meditate and yes there
are obvious health benefits that come
from that there but it's also
understanding that the smallest amount
of time that you can invest in first of
all just exiting the Mind momentarily
and being with the body is an investment
in how you interact with the rest of the
world you know so for example you know
you spend so much of your time with your
kids right and I have a daughter as well
and
if you you know like there are times
when you're so stressed and thinking
about other things that you feel that
connection to your kids is really
difficult you know you might be there
but you're not really there and we all
do it and it's very human so it's not
like it's a bad thing that we all go
through
meditation does it gives you an
opportunity to momentarily disconnect
from the hamster wheel of life where we
feel like we have to do things we have
to go somewhere there's a natural sense
of urgency that is hardwired into our
body and our mind where we feel like we
have to do this we have to do that we
have to do that and we all do have to do
so many things but it's not as urgent as
we actually think it is and what happens
when we for a moment we drop out of what
we have to do and our schedules and our
plans and our ideas and we just drop
into the body we begin to to enter into
this feeling state where we can start to
feel oh what does this moment feel like
not from the mind but like
like what does it feel like in the body
and what emotions are going on
underneath here and when someone is
communicating with you you're not trying
you're not present with them just so you
can respond to them you actually feel
their energy
and it's a whole different way of moving
through the world I find and I wish for
the first half of my daughter's life I
had I had this skill she's 21 now she's
an old woman but
um you know first half of my her life I
wasn't I wasn't doing this practice and
I was always disconnected from her but
the next you know 10 15 years of her
life I was deeply present to her so I
could be there and relate to her on an
emotional level so first understanding
why meditation is important is great we
know what the science tells us helps us
with sleep it helps us with our anxiety
depression Focus performance all of
those wonderful things but for me on a
more practical level meditation helps me
be present to the things that I want to
be present for full stop and then the
side benefits of that is that you
naturally become more compassionate you
become Kinder because you have to be
kind to yourself in the process because
you start to see that your mind and you
are actually quite crazy and that's okay
and it's normal and so you find this
sense of ease within yourself and then
you relate to the world in a much
different way the person I was before I
began a practice was someone that was
constantly consuming the world and I was
thinking about what I could get what I
could do and where I could go and and
take take take take
and the opposite after I began a
meditation practice is to relate to my
world a lot differently to become more
conscious to Choose Wisely to choose to
recycle instead of even throw out my
rubbish to choose to eat foods that will
nourish me as opposed to eat foods that
will that are just gonna satiate me in
that moment because I'm anxious and I
want something to you know get rid of
the anxiety so it develops this quality
of Consciousness that can be helpful not
just for your for yourself at work to
perform better but also outside of work
yeah and then it's actually finding a
practice that
um that you can actually do you know
five kids I would even know how to like
manage five kids but you know you might
only have five minutes if you're lucky a
day so what can you do for five minutes
every single day that's going to build
this skill within you and it's a bit
like going to the gym and doing squats
let's say right if you do squats once a
week
um it might be great but you're probably
not going to see much benefit from that
over a period of time right it's better
than nothing but it's also not really
going to develop any sort of muscle
there and it's like meditation as well
if you all you do is five minutes every
single day you'll begin to see a change
in your life as opposed to maybe sitting
30 minutes once a week so these little
incremental moments where you're deeply
present deeply cultivating your mind
you're refining your mind can really add
up and it won't show in the practice
it'll show like when you're interacting
with your kids or when you're
interacting with your husband or when
you're interacting with food or your own
mind in all those Quiet Moments and then
you'll realize oh when I have nothing to
do and no one else there I'm actually
okay like this moment is actually kind
of I'm fine with myself I love that I
love that so much I was going to ask you
to like for anybody who's intimidated at
the thought of like starting a
meditation practice like how to start
and that was just perfect it was a great
a great tidbit they're exactly like how
to just do it from the beginning and I
want to have you like expand on that but
before I love that you brought it and
connected it to Parenting because a lot
of the parenting like authors that I'm
reading and talking to on the podcast
one of the biggest advice they give is
when you're having an interaction with
your child it's easy to become very
reactionary because we're just like you
said we're so busy we're stressed we
have so much going on in our mind so
when something happens with the kids
that is take some thoughtfulness and how
to respond it's easy for us to just
react and the number one like advice is
to pause before you respond pause
take a deep breath and then then respond
because then you're in your body and
then you can be present you know because
it's so easy to just be doing this
grabbing that holding holding one kid on
one arm and you know all the other
things you got going on yeah and that's
like such a human way of interacting
with the world
um Victor Frankel once had this amazing
quote
um
I'm gonna butcher I always forget it
when I have to like retell it but um
between stimulus and a response there is
a space and in that space is your power
to choose your response and in your
response is your Doorway to freedom I
think it's something like that and the
stimulus often as parents can be the
little thing that you didn't plan for
right kids about to eat like a bug or
something like that or they're about to
drop a plate of pasta yeah or they did
drop a plate or they did yeah
um and then your natural response is so
automatic because it's habituated into
your nervous system based on your
psychology right and so what mindfulness
gives you is that space that space is
mindfulness it's that space that you get
to choose okay how am I going to respond
right now am I going to respond and be
like angry and yell which could have a
whole host of ramifications in that
moment forget long term but even in that
moment right
um or can I take a moment and notice
okay this is really bad I've been
triggered I can feel the anger I can
feel the disappointment I can feel the
frustration and I can allow it to pass
and then I can respond and the second
way can be much more skillful for how
the rest of your day is going to go or
maybe the next 20 minutes when you don't
have a screaming kid right right there
and then or it can be the opposite and
it takes time right like I I hear all of
the apprehension from so many people
that I've been teaching to and it's been
thousands over 15 years right now and
the invitation is to begin slowly and to
give yourself some Grace and give
yourself some compassion
um but you know
when I think about having kids right now
I'm just so grateful that I have a
practice that can give me that space
because honestly I don't know how I
would do it without it and I'm sewing
awe of all the mothers and fathers out
there that can do it you know that don't
ever practice and I'm like teach me your
ways
well but it can only benefit to start
like you said to just start five minutes
a day So for anybody listening Jack
definitely go to the open app which is
it's just your app is the most beautiful
app I've ever seen and I open it and I
just feel like this is where I'm
supposed to be and I want to make it a
priority when I'm there so I started
doing the meditation practices and the
breath work is be is like so I feel like
that's like a whole nother level can you
explain breath work the power of that
and why we should do it yeah so um you
know app's been designed for people that
have been thinking for the longest time
I can't meditate and so we're like What
are the doorways into this very human
quality of presence and connection and
so you know there are moments for
example you when you're with one of your
kids that you're very mindful right and
all of us all of us have moments whether
we're out surfing whether we're cooking
there are moments where all of our our
attention and our awareness and we're in
these flow states are on the experience
that we're having but there's also ways
to tap into that and meditation is one
way but breath work is also another way
and breath work has been around as long
as meditation has been around you know
from all the way in the Judea Christian
times to you know the yogis that taught
ways to control this thing that we all
have which is our breath to elicit a
certain feeling meditation is something
that changes your mind over a period of
time breath work is something that
changes your physiological State just
like that and you know if you are
feeling tired you can do literally five
breaths of
and you'll be like oh summing's changed
right
um or if you know you're about to go to
sleep and you're feeling really wired
you can do a breathing practice that
will calm your nervous system down the
difference with meditation is meditation
is more a skill that evolves over time
that 100 think will change your mind and
change your life but the immediacy of
breath work is something that you can't
ignore it and when you combine the two
for people that say they can't meditate
you're able to first of all be like oh
okay I feel different it's like when you
do 10 burpees right you're like oh just
like I feel different yeah and it's the
same thing because for so long everyone
that meditates has been like is it
working like I don't know because it's
so subtle but breath work is something
that's so immediate and there's a whole
range from breath work that's been
invented 3000 years ago to breath work
at their views on Navy Seals and you
know NBA players all of it allows you to
change your physiological state to a
desired outcome which is a slight
difference to meditation which is you
don't know how your outcome is going to
change and it takes a subtle amount of
time to actually get there so would you
say people should listen to a breath
work class and then do a meditation one
or do you does it matter which order no
it doesn't really matter and I think so
much of meditation is experimenting yeah
um when when you're new to meditation
practice a lot of people like guided
meditations so you might you know oh I
like this person's voice yeah I don't
really connect to this person's voice
um oh I like this style of technique and
not this style of technique I find for
people that have a really overactive
mind breath work is a really good place
to begin with a down regulative breath
of practice and then from there they've
got to experience presence perhaps for
the very first time then they can add on
like a five minute meditation practice
um you know me I still do my sequence of
meditation every day for the last 16
years is a 10 minute breath work
practice a 15-minute meditation practice
and then another 20 minute meditation
practice I sequenced that on yeah and so
um yeah it's a cool way to begin to to
explore these practices and does it
matter what time of the day that you do
it I'm guessing you're gonna be like
anytime just get it in but it doesn't
matter I mean it depends I find the time
when your mind is the least active
personally and for the majority of
people I've taught is the morning
because I've just woken up they haven't
maybe checked their phones maybe they
don't have a screaming child jumping on
them
um so if you know for parents it's
definitely wherever you can do it
um but ideally if you can find a
consistent time to do it that's great
because it then becomes a ritual you
know you ritualize the experience of
sitting in a place this is your time
even if it's five minutes you can do it
but honestly like any time of day is
great
um but you just find it where you but
you just get it in where you can fit it
in yeah for me I'm finding it uh easiest
to do is after the kids go to bed
because they're honestly sleep and I
know no one's gonna be like coming in or
interrupting and I can just okay
everyone is down that's when I can
really decompress because I know
everyone's safe and sound and asleep
yeah for me the morning is definitely
like as soon as I wake up like I'm being
woken up by right by little children
yeah I mean and there's two ways we
experience mindfulness one is through
the practice which you're doing in the
evening but in another way we cultivate
the same qualities is through what we
call the informal practice of
mindfulness we all want beautiful
comfortable clothing that's also
flattering to your body Indigo Luna is
Yoga Chic these are the types of clothes
that you can rock day to day whether
you're at home doing dishes going to
your favorite yoga class or shopping at
the grocery store well at least the
grocery store part works for Maui
standards I'm not sure if anywhere else
it really works because here if you see
someone wearing heels and a pencil skirt
at the grocery store in Hawaii it's
clear that they don't live here anyways
Indigo Luna has ethically made yoga wear
swimwear where Intimates and loungewear
they are slow fashion and sustainably
sourced with beautiful simple shapes
earthy colors and plant dyes from
recycled or organic materials everything
is cut sewn and dyed by a loving human
hand and they ensure that every person
involved in production Works in
comfortable safe conditions I love
supporting companies with conscious
practices it feels good to vote with my
dollars in this way and it really is a
win-win situation here because these
clothes feel so comfortable on my body
they hug and hold my curves just right
so enter the code Ellen 10 for 10 off
your order or click the link in my show
notes
which I'm sure you do so much in your
day which is just being present to what
you're doing you know when when you're
one of your children is talking to you
you're really listening you're not on
your phone when you're cooking you're
really smelling the Aromas you're
touching the ingredients like when your
senses are immersed in one moment that's
also mindfulness so the combination of
those two you're really building that
skill of mindfulness it's it's not just
the meditation that that's important uh
one of my teachers used to say like it's
no point meditating for five minutes
every day and then being a jerk for the
rest of the day right you're not really
developing that skill so you take what
you're doing for five minutes into your
day and you're really creating a
holistic mindfulness experience yeah
because I think so many people whether
the kids are not you
finding ways yourself to feel busy busy
you like that almost everyone I know
feels busy like people say oh how are
you oh good just busy you know that's
almost always the answer no matter
whether you have five kids or one or
none or whatever it's kind of crazy how
our culture is like that I know right
like we I think we we glorify it a lot
um and I'm sure genuinely people are
busy but we do we definitely do we do
glorify and I also think it's we don't
know how to rest and rest for some of us
is like I'll just be on my phone Doom
scrolling while I'm resting
um or I'll be you know doing things that
aren't really restful so it's it's a
it's a cultural thing that a lot of us
uh um are grappling with myself included
and even in the especially in the age of
social media and Tech and how we've
become so much more accustomed to
um getting a bunch of things at once
like like even most people probably
listen to this podcast aren't just
sitting down listening to a podcast
they're probably driving they're
probably cooking they're they're doing
something else or at least that's a lot
of times when I'm listening to podcasts
um or anything else like Tick Tock the
age of tick tock and how it has made our
attention span so so short eight seconds
actually eight seconds yeah and um it
was funny I read this article it was
about 15 years old now 10 years old
where um goldfish used to be eight
seconds and we used to be nine seconds
so it was like one of the shortest
attention spans ever and now we've
dropped below that wow and um for anyone
that's watched like is it finding Dora
or Finding Dory
um it talks about dory's friend that
always always forgetting stuff I feel
like that sometimes you know in my day
I'm like what was I doing yeah and you
know probably had that moment where
you've gone for a drive and you're like
how did I get here like what roads did I
cross or you've gone to the next room
and you're like what did I come to do
and um and that's just the byproduct of
how much we're overworking our mind yeah
you know and how dopamine it leaves our
body we're craving that and how
exhausted we most of us are yeah and I
also think some things are just kind of
inevitable to like taking kids for
example that we've mentioned there was
one time when all the kids were outside
watering the plants with Andrew after
the kids had we had all eaten dinner and
I was washing the dishes and that hadn't
happened for a while like normally
there's at least a few kids in the house
or someone's like talking to me or
helping me do the dishes or whatever I
was just by myself doing the dishes and
nothing else and I was like
incredible yeah like nothing there was
nothing else I was thoroughly enjoying
my dishwashing time I'm like this is so
peaceful right now and not not that I
don't enjoy the chaos I do that's the
reason why I had five kids I love my
children I love being with them and
Andrew and I often say oh I can't even
imagine if we had only had three if we
stopped at three life would be so boring
we think it's so much fun having all
five of them together and totally but
there are moments for sure where I'm
like wow like what it feels like to just
be doing one thing at a time well it's
so interesting you say that because um
you know one of the the seminal pieces
of research that a lot of mindfulness
researchers talk about is a piece um
called a Wandering mind is an unhappy
mind it's by two researchers called
Killingsworth and Gilbert and they did
this research piece on on happiness and
and attention and what they showed is
that it doesn't matter where your mind
it doesn't matter what you're thinking
about right so you could be here
thinking about a holiday thinking about
a a pleasant moment you're still not as
happy as doing an activity where you're
fully engaged so the example of you
really being present and washing those
dishes you're registering so much more
happiness right in that moment than if
you were sitting you know idly maybe
you're mowing the lawn but you're
thinking about this holiday that's
coming up and it really speaks to the
power of attention you know where where
our mind goes energy really flows as
they say and um it can be anything it
can be washing dishes it could be
gardening you'd be cleaning toilets but
if you're really engaged there that
there's something within your neural
circuits that actually registers a sense
of happiness in your body yeah and can
you talk a little bit about
um practicing like Detachment in our
lives and the benefits of that
yeah I think you know um
Detachment is probably not the word I
would use I think the word I would use
is non-attachment and
um the distinction there is Detachment
it feels like we have to get rid of
something it feels like we have to like
cut something off oh yeah true um
whereas non-attachment is just
recognizing that there are things in our
life that we don't have to hook onto and
develop a sense of identity around or
cling to it because clinging to anything
really causes suffering in in our
tradition
um so non-attachment really is a way in
which we can cultivate more happiness
contentment in our lives and an example
of that could be
um our bodies right so many of us are
attached to the way we look and uh we do
all sorts of things to change how we
look to feel how we look but we know
inevitably our bodies change over time
you know show your body change after you
had your first child right my bodies
change after I started a tech you know
app and stuff like that
um and so if we can begin to understand
there is this thing within us that is
constantly changing and evolving not
just our bodies but our financial
situations our relationships our
relationships change over time and so
what we tend to do is we get attached to
how things are at any one given moment
you know and an example is the honeymoon
period of a relationship so many people
are like I was so good like he or she or
they were so amazing at this point in
time like now they just don't look at me
or they don't acknowledge me or they
don't want to spend the same amount of
time with me but it's it's the reality
that things change right
I'm sure you and your husband when you
had the honeymoon period to like you
with five kids is so different right
um and and so recognizing how everything
is in a constant state of flux in a
constant uh state of change allows us to
not be attached to things
now if we can cultivate this sense of
non-attachment to many different areas
of our life
our feelings all these things then it
just allows us to not be as stressed and
as and experience as much mental tension
as we sometimes tend to do but this is
really hard you know because we are so
attached to so many things because it
gives us meaning and it gives us an
identity in our lives so that's where
practices like meditation can really
help us but also just really reflecting
on things like
for anyone listening or watching right
now like what am I unwilling to let go
of right now you can think of it like
that and it can sometimes be a memory it
can sometimes be you know this
relationship that ended five years ago
I'm not willing to give that up or it
could be the the the fact that we hate
our ex oh we have ill feeling towards
them
um because it feels good to to have that
feeling and sometimes it's scary to not
be attached because then it's just us
and it's an unknown sort of quality and
feeling but really there is a tremendous
Freedom that naturally arises after that
when you're not attached to things
um you can move through the world with a
lot more freedom now it doesn't mean
things aren't painful when things end
but it means you can move through them a
little bit more quicker because you
embody whatever it is you're feeling and
you realize that it's not personal this
is just life things are always changing
just the awareness of of everything you
just described for non-attachment is
something I think a lot of us aren't
even thinking about and for example you
brought up we are attached to our looks
even just right before this podcast I'm
like fixing my hair checking my makeup
and I think a lot of it is driven our
attachment is driven by fear and like
what you said so for me it might be fear
of being criticized fear of people
thinking that I'm I look a certain way
in a negative light and that fear drives
oh I gotta make sure that I my hair
looks good and my makeup like that's the
attachment you're talking about so if
that wasn't there if I had that
non-attachment how much easier it is to
just be present in the moment that
you're talking about yeah and and you
know there's some natural things that
we're always going to do and it's fine
and we shouldn't worry too much about it
right but um I was doing the same thing
for everyone watching I'm like my shirt
um but I I think it's kind of first of
all identifying the feeling that's
driving that right like oh there's a
fear
where is this fear in my body what is it
what does it feel like and then for
example fear for me sometimes I feel it
in my chest it's like the heart beating
quickly or there's a tightness and if
I'm really present to it if I meditate
on okay just the feeling of the fear
then I might start to naturally
recognize that that fear is based on
something that happened like 20 years
ago or this idea that I have to look a
certain way in order to please my mom or
my dad or Society or culture and then we
can begin to understand the fear and
then we can lose our attachment to that
if we can understand where that fear
comes from we can just let it go if
we're willing to do that if we're
capable and well resourced enough to do
it but it takes a little bit of time to
get yeah right and that is so similar to
what I was talking about before we
started this podcast interview when I
was talking about my friend Heather
McKean about mind change methods it
really goes back to what's the original
source of why you have this this feeling
where did you first learn that this is
your truth that this is the truth right
what's the first time the story the
pictures the images the feeling in your
gut that you felt or your chest like you
said and then you you have to
acknowledge those go to it and be
willing to rework rework those memories
or like you said Let It Go is a very
similar type thing because a lot of the
things in the mind change method that I
was talking about
um is about letting it go so it might be
an image like if you're feeling if
you're feeling your um emotions based on
through a picture like for you you said
like it was a physical feeling so it's
like letting go of a physical feeling of
your chest but if it's a picture you can
have the picture of putting those
feelings and that story in a box and
then attaching it to a balloon and
letting it float away and like that I
feel like that is part of a like a
meditation practice Yeah I mean there's
so many different ways for us to process
um negative thoughts feelings and
emotions all unhelpful thoughts feelings
and emotions and sounds like a great way
to do it another way to do it is just to
feel it you know and so much of the
discomfort we feel in our lives is
because we're unwilling to feel what we
should feel you know if someone breaks
up with us that hurts yes and like allow
it to hurt allow it to allow it to
really break your heart and then then
let it go because it heals over time
because if you look at impermanence and
how things constantly change
relationships change and perhaps they
end but then that feeling of pain also
ends at some point you know and then
you'll move into a place of happiness
but a lot of what we do is we move
through the world and on our emotional
World avoiding feelings and and kind of
dodging them and trying to make sense of
them and creating a story around it
where it's sometimes quicker and more
helpful to just feel it absolutely
absolutely yeah and that actually is
part of the Mind change like you figure
out where the source was that you go and
make it as strong as possible in your
mind and let yourself feel it and then
after you've done that then you can like
read work it and let it go that's
beautiful yeah so how can you be more
present and connected in your life like
you gave the example some little
examples but like in what way other than
just taking a breath can you practice
that better as you're going through it
for anybody because a lot of people feel
busy yeah I mean just connect your
senses throughout the course of your day
is a good one to do
um you know being out here Maui's really
beautiful because there's so many
beautiful sounds and any moment that I
feel really you know in my head I just
list I just notice what I'm hearing and
I'll hear all like is that a frog you
were saying before yeah Coco frog I'm
hearing like frog sounds I'm hearing
bird sounds there's a distant lowmower
like there's so many things going on and
so the moment you tune out of the head
and you tune into your senses you're
already connected to the present moment
another another great exercise is if
you're in transit if you're on a train
or if you're driving just notice like
what your clothes feel like against your
body maybe not if you're driving because
it might be a little dangerous but
um if you're in a train or if you're in
transit somehow
um you know plant your feet onto the
ground notice what the feet feel like
against your shoes or the Earth or what
your shirt feels like against your skin
or
um you know what your hand feels like
against your thigh again you're dropping
out of the mind and having a very
somatic mindfulness experience right
there and another simple one is to just
drop completely into the body and just
ask yourself what am I feeling right now
and not try to make sense of what you're
feeling or process what you're feeling
or understand it but just like drop in
and
what am I feeling and you might notice
like for me sometimes there's like a bit
of anxiety in my chest and I can just be
with the heart beating quickly like that
and I'm like oh cool
right now I'm feeling this and already
I'm present with my reality
um so there are so many different ways
if you're eating food like a really cool
ways like when you're eating notice all
the different flavors as you eat so many
of us and me by the way went to this
I've got to give a shout out to like
Maui pies
um had the most insane uh banana cream
pie oh I know what you're talking about
you know it's so good and my fiance is
looking at me and she's like
you just literally inhale that because
I'm like
so great and she's like on her first
bite and um a way to practice mindful
eating is to like take a bite smell it
look at it look at all the textures look
at all the different things that there
put it in your mouth like notice really
before swallowing all the different
flavors that are happening in your mouth
then swallow it wait for a moment notice
what the aftertaste is like and eat in a
way like that that first of all you'll
become full so quickly you won't eat as
much you'll enjoy your food a lot more
and you Savor that experience and you're
also essentially having a mindful
experience as you eat so there are so
many different ways to to experience
mindfulness if you tune into your senses
in that same way I think it's become a
really big normalcy for people to not
just sit and eat in quiet it's almost
always with somebody else or on your
phone or just doing work at the same
time and you really can't do what you
just described yeah and also people
might be like okay but why why should I
do that but really like you said the
science really is there on the benefits
of not feeling so stressed out all day
yeah like that is just that's a
longevity tool right there you know
what's really apparent on this trip is
that you know us humans aren't meant to
go with the pace that culture is asking
us to go at
um and that's true whatever your job is
these days you know if you're an average
person connected to the internet like
you're going at a certain speed that
feels really difficult and some people
are built like that some people can
operate at that speed and I'm always
like so I I think I need to be like that
person I'm like oh this person's going
like that I can do it and then you know
you're served all of these ads on
Instagram saying you know just grind
just hustle just do this and you start
to think yeah there's something wrong
with me if I don't go at that pace and
what I've come to the conclusion of is
that some of us are a bit more sensitive
and our gifts are in in doing other
other things you know like being in
touch with people and really
understanding nature and there's so many
different things that that becomes your
superpower that for the majority of
people going at that pace just isn't
sustainable you can go for a period of
time but then you crash and burn like
like I tend to do often
um and so it's really understanding like
what is your speed what what's your
speed and if you're ex if you're going
at a quick speed then really take those
moments to unwind whine down and rest
because that speed for anyone isn't
really sustainable for a long period of
time yeah I think because that must come
down right totally I I have the the
struggle of just wanting to do so many
things like I never feel like there's
enough time because time is like our
greatest value it's like totally the
most important thing that we give aways
every single day right so what are we
giving our time for and I always have
that if someone asks what's the
superpower you can have if you could
have super power it would be to pause
time so I could just pause it get
everything done I want to get done and
then click play yeah because I just
never by the end of every day it's like
so many things on my list but like you
said so much of the stuff that we think
is urgent isn't actually as urgent as we
make it out yeah and it takes like a
meditation mindfulness awareness
practice to realize that things begin to
move a little slower when your mind
moves a little slower and if you're
constantly attached to you know the
internet social media your phone
calendars
you're going to be expected to move at a
certain Pace but when you slow it down
when you slow yourself down it doesn't
mean like you become less
disciplined or you perform less but it
means things just move in slow motion
for you and you have the resources to be
able to do it it's kind of like that
Matrix scene where they're kind of going
in slow motion it's it's like that you
know you can see things unfolding and
you're not reactive at that moment you
can you can go at a pace where you're
just meeting it and it becomes just a
lot healthier I mean I've definitely met
people who have a very consistent
meditation practice and I can feel the
difference like they're in my house and
I'm just like
aren't we are we supposed to why are you
so calm well you know I know you feel
like there's something wrong with you
you're like why am I like you like this
because but it brings awareness like oh
wait I'm operating at this super fast
speed and I mean it just makes me think
of relationships when you talked about
how different our relationships were at
the beginning to where they are now I
had mentioned something recently to my
husband like oh I would love it if we
could like make the space to just sit
and talk more and he's like what are you
talking about we talk all the time we
talk all day and I'm like oh yeah like
okay you're going to baseball practice
bye or oh you're changing the baby's
diaper okay good okay I'm gonna make
lunch you you do the kids home school
like that's not talking yeah
I'm talking about yeah yeah no it's true
intentionality you know it's like five
minutes let's just like let's just be
here yeah this moment
it's hot it's really hard yeah so I
empathize for some people too like
talking like different personalities
right some people are more into the
talking and some people are more quiet
that's one thing that like drew me to my
husband because he was like just more
quiet and I have such a talkative person
that's why I started a podcast because I
love talking
I'm so good at like being quiet and
listening which is really also part of
mindfulness living I think yeah it must
be a beautiful balance between you two
it is it's good it's pretty good at
certain times someone had said in the
last conversation I had I mentioned
something about how I have a lot of
feelings and that my husband might be
like okay we got more feelings all right
let's be ready for it she's like well
that's probably why he was drawn to you
in the first place was because of your
big feelings and he might not even
realize that that was one thing that
Drew him to you because you have
something that maybe he's not doing
right you bring it out in him and vice
versa I know so can you talk about your
app a little bit your open app what how
did you start it and how did it come to
be yeah I mean so it's it's really a
beautiful team effort um there's three
co-founders
um that I met during the pandemic
actually just before the pandemic and
they each bring this really unique skill
set Peter is incredible when it comes to
the tech uh ride is our CEO he's
incredible at managing the whole company
and I really bring experience around and
the experience the content and
recruiting and teachers and together our
desire was to really bring more people
into this world of mindfulness because
there were so many barriers you know
when I started practicing there was no
one my age first of all that was doing
it and it felt so formal it felt like
there was something wrong with me if I
looked at everyone next to me and they
were just so Serene and still I'm like
holy like I'm there's something
really wrong with me but we learned now
that the evolution of mindfulness is
really about
um dropping it's not really about the
mind so much it's more about integrating
the mind and the body and so somatic
mindfulness has is having a bit of a
Renaissance and somatic mindfulness is
experiencing mindfulness through the the
physique the physicality of your
experience right
um and so breath work is one doorway
into that which is so immediate and so
quick that anyone can really do it
because everyone is breathing and if
you're not breathing then I don't know
if you're alive right now yeah um so
anyone can have access to that but then
there are movement practices that really
offer you this moment where you can be
working hard and be mindful right you
can just stop as you're working hard and
be like what's going on inside yeah and
you're like oh you notice the heart
beating quickly cool or you can be
working out really hard and the teachers
drawing attention to what you're feeling
yeah or checking in with your breath or
bringing attention to what the physical
experience is like when you're in a yoga
shape yes and so cultivating awareness
is like an evolution of what mindfulness
is and it's even like that in your hit
in the hit classes I feel like I'm
hearing sounds better in these classes
just like the way the way that you're
highlighting certain sounds and then the
way that they're reminding you to check
in with your body and your breath like
even in the hit classes which I love
yeah thank you so um then we've got the
most incredible teachers you know we
could find all around the world from
um London Canada Australia
um the US and you know they're all based
in in Venice and we deliver classes that
anyone can join for more around the
world and they can do live classes so a
lot of we started this during the
pandemic and one of the problems was
everyone was alone they were by
themselves and mindfulness is so much
more than just yourself it's about how
you interact with each other it
cultivates connection so we developed
technology that enables you to practice
with people and chat to people that are
in the class at the same time so you can
be like hey Mary how you doing how's
your dog and I see this every time when
I'm about to join a class and like oh my
dog's great how's your cat
and then they can turn on their cameras
and then I get to see them in their
living rooms and then they can obviously
interact with me interact with each
other we practice together so yeah we've
got this incredible technology that that
really connects you to a community of
practitioners and these aren't your
run-of-the-mill like everyone's like a
serious meditator everyone just has like
lives and they're trying to like learn
and grow and it's just someone like me
like I'm like okay I need I need to
start this let's do it yeah yeah
everyone's just like figuring it out so
um yeah it's a really beautiful app and
you know I think you mentioned the
design of it earlier on and the design
is is intentional because people are
drawn to beautiful things and it's just
a natural nationally ingrained within us
oh my gosh yes but like that is so so
true like there's other apps that I've
that I've gone to like movement apps and
tried it and there's something different
about yours it just attracts me to it
because of its beauty and its aesthetic
yeah it's a mindful design like we've
really thought about how can we design
an app that people uh like hey want to
be associated with but also people want
to engage within in ways so um that's
from everything that our production
staff have done so that's the set design
to like all the different you know
practices that you can do
um it's just a really it's just another
way to get you into the practice really
yeah and I I'm so glad that you brought
up breath work being just a little bit
more attainable for people who are new
to it because I definitely found that to
be the case when I started doing the
breath work classes I'm like okay I can
definitely do this the meditation I find
so intimidating still but that's just
something I said just for me it's my
mind like when I do it I sit down but
five minutes is doable for sure like
okay I can do five minutes I think a
good way to think about it if you is the
let go of the expectations right like I
don't it's like let's just experiment
like maybe I'm not gonna come out
feeling calm or whatever it is but like
let's just treat it as I call it the lab
like in my life I have these moments
where I'm like oh let's go into the lab
and see what happens so I might do you
know I might do fasting for like two
weeks it's a lab experience or I might
try Pilates for two weeks it's like a
lab or I might try just green juices or
whatever it is and at the end of it I'm
like oh do I feel different to something
change and then I'm like oh maybe I'll
stick with her maybe I won't do it and
that's okay right then you can go back
to breath work or yoga or movement
practice but if people think of
meditation as being like a real
experiment
um let's just give it a go and and see
like what happens then you let go of a
lot of the expectations you have yeah
and if you let go of the expectations it
becomes a more enjoyable process and um
maybe it'll stick yeah and the
difference
length of class
I would try one that's on you know a
long time ago somewhere else and it
would be like 20 minutes long I'm like
oh my gosh this is hard yeah like
sitting here and then it's like bring it
back to your body and you keep like my
mind Trails that's like bring it back to
the body yeah but I think the five
minutes is like where I'm at right now
that's really helpful that's how I
started I started with five minutes I
did that for about eight months eight
nine months and then oh really I was
like oh okay like now I feel like
something is different yeah and then I
went to 10 minutes and then eventually
longer sets it's but yeah I mean think
big start small yeah is my is my motto
yeah so good like it just makes me think
of my kids two of my older kids go to
like a Homeschool Group
um twice a week and the first time that
they came back like how was it how did
you like it because the rest of the days
of the week we do homeschool at home but
this was something new that we had tried
and she they're like it was great but
they made us sit still for 15 minutes
and do nothing
really like he said yeah because then
like we would sit there or not supposed
to say anything like not really supposed
to talk it's supposed to be alone and
the teacher I'm like what did what did
the teachers say and he said
she said that you know it's good to sit
by yourself with your thoughts because
then you start to see the world around
you you start to see things you wouldn't
see before like maybe you'll see a stick
in the sand and feel creative and want
to draw something in the sand that you
wouldn't normally do that if you weren't
just sitting alone so I thought that was
really cool that like that's something
that to develop in children yeah yeah I
mean yeah the next child if I'm lucky
enough to have any more children I'm
going to be taking them to every
Meditation Retreat I go on because um
it's it's really
for most people growing up in cities
like for kids it's it's tough because
right the stimulus is is there and
things like Tick Tock and the pressure
of culture so yeah I think if I grew up
in this time I would probably be pretty
sick yeah truthfully totally there's so
much going on yeah in the world so to
kind of round out this discussion how
else can we create cultivate a
disciplined Mind through that
yeah so a disciplined mind can be
cultivated through many ways I like to
think of this analogy of commas and full
stops
full stops like things that you can
bookend your day with and that can be
like just meditation sits and when I say
meditation I'm also using breath work or
whatever it is whatever it is your
meditation so if you start your day with
five minutes or end your day with five
minutes that's like a full stop it book
ends your day right it's just time just
for you to intentionally focus on
something or cultivate something like
compassion kindness whatever it is and
then throughout the day there are what
we call commas and these are the little
moments that punctuate your day where
you're washing the dishes like oh this
is a comma right here or I'm just
present with what I'm doing I'm going
for a walk I'm going to leave my phone
behind and I'm going to notice what I
see I'm going to take in what I hear
um you know I'm cooking I'm really in
that moment and that's these little acts
really build towards it's you know
something much greater
specific practices you can focus on are
like concentration practices or focused
practices where your mind is just
focusing on one specific thing so it
could be sounds
and that's a great way to begin it could
be from I also began looking at a candle
flame whereas it's like every time my
mind wandered away from the candle flame
I would just come back to it over and
over and over again and that helps build
this quality of gathering your attention
into into one thing but really it's
recognizing the moments that you are no
longer mindful
is a moment of mindfulness and so every
time you're like oh I've drifted off
into this
now I'm Mindful and like the irony of
that is kind of really funny because I
tell people the moment you realize
you're no longer present is the moment
you become present and um just that
recognition that you're not here is so
powerful wow that's really inspiring I
definitely feel inspired by this because
I am like I said earlier just one of
those people that's like check things
off my to-do list get it done and I do
consider myself like present with my
kids but when it's like work time or or
even there'll be certain times
throughout the day when I'm present with
my kids but then I lose that presence
because I'm like oh I gotta do this and
so it's like a back and forth it's
definitely something like a practice
yeah for sure it's a practice Yeah it's
I want to just tell everyone that like
don't beat yourself up if you do it like
I still beat myself up sometimes
um if my mind wanders away it's so
normal and they call it a practice for a
reason but it's like anything you know
you invest a little bit of time you get
better you get better at it the more you
do it so think big start small and just
be gentle with yourself yeah absolutely
and I I think I always go back to like
what are the benefits like why should we
do this because I'm such a like task
oriented person but it always just
reminds me of like how easily
self-induced stress is like how much we
do that to ourselves how we add stress
to our lives that doesn't need to be
there yeah and so these practices that
you're mentioning the benefits
absolutely and a good way to maybe end
it is if you feel it's difficult to for
people that feel it's difficult to do it
for themselves
um think of who you're doing a full
like what would who would benefit from
me being kinda less stressed sleeping
better more present like you know is it
my partner is it my kids is it my dog is
it my work and myself and myself right
exactly so that can also be a useful
tool cool thank you so much for being
here and I'm so glad that we had this
conversation thank you
thanks all right bye everybody
thank you
[Music]